mencioné en los últimos vídeos que el
coeficiente de fricción cinética tiende
a ser menor o igual que el coeficiente
de fricción estática verdad y quizás
esto te haya llevado a una pregunta que
he tenido al menos yo en mi cabeza y que
y que aún tengo hasta cierto punto y es
y es porque esta desigualdad ocurre
porque el coeficiente de fricción
cinética es menor o igual que el
coeficiente de fricción estática y la
mejor teoría que al menos puedo
visualizar en mi mente basado en las
lecturas que he hecho es es que la
diferencia entre bueno veámoslo así
digamos que aquí tengo aquí voy a tener
el en mi bloque de siempre
el bloque de siempre ok y digamos que
está sobre cierta superficie
y sobre cierta superficie y vamos a
imaginar que este bloque es estático que
hay en este no se está moviendo y vamos
a pensar en ese mismo bloque
mismo bloque o que no se ve muy similar
verdad ahí está más o menos es el mismo
bloque y ahora éste se está moviendo a
velocidad constante muy bien entonces
vamos a suponer que este bloque de aquí
se mueve a velocidad constante muy bien
y vamos a tratar de ver por qué es
cierta esta desigualdad o por qué porque
siempre o tiende a ser cierta pues ok
entonces este cuerpo se mueve a
velocidad constante quiere decir que a
éste le corresponde el coeficiente de
fricción estática ya esté el coeficiente
de fricción cinética
entonces en otras palabras si esta
desigualdad de cierta significa que
aplicar más fuerza para superar la
fricción estática necesita uno aplicar
más fuerza para superar la fricción
estática que para acelerar lo que ya se
está moviendo de antemano verdad
entonces hay este
en este caso hay una menor respuesta de
la fricción ahora para para tratar de
entender esto vamos a verlo
vamos a hacer digamos un acercamiento al
nivel microscópico atómico de hecho
entonces digamos que aquí están las
moléculas que conforman el la superficie
digamos donde se está está parado el el
bloque más o menos no sé quizás pueda
tener esta configuración lo que sí hay
que recordar es que es que a niveles
atómicos las cosas no son suaves no se
ven como líneas se ven de esta forma y
puede ser que las moléculas del bloque
tengan esta configuración digamos
esto está estático verdad entonces a lo
mejor se ve así más o menos a lo mejor
aquí hay moléculas que van entrando ok
ya lo mejor acá también entran las
moléculas quién sabe puede ser que
tengan esta configuración pero el
detalle es que esta configuración es
fija ok entonces en este caso ya que lo
estamos viendo en nivel atómico y que de
hecho podemos tener una interpretación o
más bien podemos irnos como a ideas
filosóficas muy raras en realidad nada
en el mundo está en contacto si tú lo
piensas de esa forma en realidad son los
electrones y los protones los que
provocan una fuerza electromagnética de
repulsión verdad y eso es lo que no
permite acercarse a las moléculas hoy
han visto a nivel macroscópico que por
ejemplo en la superficie no permita que
se acerque más está esta caja ok
entonces por ejemplo si tú estás
empujando la caja en realidad no es que
tú les des empujando sino que los
electrones que están en tu mano
tienen provocan una fuerza de repulsión
sobre el objeto que estés empujando y
bueno ya nada más para que te vuele la
cabeza de la curiosidad y de hecho te
invito a que vean los vídeos de química
para más o menos entender un poco más al
respecto
y es que esencialmente los átomos tienen
mucho espacio vacío esto es porque el
espacio donde uno puede hallar un
electrón es mucho más grande que la masa
o el tamaño de un electrón entonces en
realidad son son fuerzas de espacios
vacíos verdad no sé les digo eso son
cosas bastante curiosas el detalle es
que por ejemplo si nos fijamos en en
este pedazo ok en este pedazo en
realidad si yo quiero mover este cuerpo
a lo mejor tengo que primero romper
estas moléculas o empujar las o hacer
algo para que puedan salir de este hueco
que está aquí formado entonces hay
muchísima fuerza que aplicar tenemos que
romperla tenemos que que empujar el
resto
que puedan al menos subir a lo mejor
romper las moléculas que se encuentran
unidas aquí en la superficie hay
muchísimas fuerzas de donde hay que
estar modificando para que esto pueda
deslizarse sin embargo si nosotros lo
vemos digamos en el otro caso digamos
digamos que tenemos más o menos la misma
la misma configuración
algo así
más o menos y ahora vamos a suponer que
este cuerpo se mueve a velocidad
constante entonces puede ser que se vea
más o menos así pero como se está
moviendo pues a lo mejor éstas no tienen
tanta oportunidad de caer a lo mejor
unas pocas sí pero no tienen tanta
oportunidad de caerse en estos huecos
muy bien entonces puede ser que si
estamos moviendo esto no tenga tanta
oportunidad de estar cayendo en estos
huecos ahora
la fricción entonces de dónde vendría si
no es de estar removiendo moléculas
rompiendo las y demás entonces ésta
puede ser que venga de los enlaces
químicos que se van generando entre las
moléculas por supuesto acá también va a
haber enlaces químicos verdad que se van
generando nada más de la cercanía sin
embargo aquí también hay otras fuerzas
que interactúan acá no acá sólo están
digamos o quizás la mayor parte de las
fuerzas que interactúan son del
rompimiento de los enlaces químicos y de
ahí es de donde viene
y ahora por supuesto que todo esto que
hemos estado comentando es realmente la
intuición que hay detrás de por qué está
desigualdad de cierta ok de hecho es
todo un área de investigación y no es
algo que alguien solo se saca de la
manga es una investigación seria la que
hacen los físicos para tratar de
entender este tipo de fenómenos pero
bueno al menos para nosotros es muy
divertido pensar qué es lo que ocurre a
nivel atómico y esta es la intuición
general de por qué el coeficiente de
fricción estática es mayor o igual que
el coeficiente de freaks de fricción
cinética